[Music]  victims are not only tricked into paying  the money and being exploited they are  being subjected to violence labor and  sexual exploitation even during their  journey there's a shocking incident this  year in the Mediterranean where migrants  were forced onto an already overcrowded  vessel they left the shore of Libya they  went out to sea and then at gunpoint to  have the engine taken away from the boat  200 of the migrants were forcibly had  their lifejackets removed and they were  just left abandoned to their own fate  and many of them lost their lives until  a rescue vessel could come here these  criminals have no scruples no principles  they will make a dollar out of your  death if they can they don't care about  it  [Music]